Alaska Airlines is
now grounding
its entire fleet of Boeing 737
nine max planes
after a terrifying trip on Friday.
Alaska Airlines
Flight 1282 had just taken off
from Portland, Oregon,
when a section of its cabin ripped off,
leaving a gaping hole,
as you see right there in the jet
with more than 170 passengers on board.
One passenger
captured the scene during the very tense
but silent moments
after the incident happened.
They are all nearly paralyzed in fear.
Their plane was only airborne
for about 20 minutes
before the pilot made an emergency
landing back in Portland.
One person was taken to the hospital
with a minor injury.
Another passenger describes
the harrowing ordeal.
I understand talking to a lady
who was sitting in the row
immediately behind
where the panel blew up, that there was a
you could see later
that there was a two window
section panel that blew out.
It's about as wide as a refrigerator
and about two thirds as high.
And she said there was,
I guess a boy
and his mother were sitting in that row
and his shirt was sucked
off him and out of the plane
and his mother was holding on to him.
And she said her own little
boy's phone went out to
incredible.
CNN aviation
correspondent Pete Martin is tracking
all the latest developments.
Pete, I mean, what do we know
about how this happened?
This happened in a really explosive
moment, Fredricka.
Like the most violent convertible rod
you've ever been on, in this case,
a Boeing 737 max, nine in row 26,
where there could have been a door.
This plane did not have it
known as a door plug.
More on that in a second.
This really happened in a bang.
7 minutes into the flight
and 16,000 feet.
This plane experienced
what is technically known
as a rapid decompression
in the high pressure,
breathable air inside
goes rushing outside,
the cold, thin air outside
comes rushing inside.
And you heard about that boy
who had his shirt pulled off.
The oxygen mask came down.
The pilots had to deal with this
very quickly.
And I want you to listen to the calm
from the new air
traffic control recordings we just got.
Step one, fly the airplane.
Step two, run
the checklist, descend
back down to breathable air.
You don't have a lot
of consciousness time in 16,000 feet.
And then communicate
to air traffic control what is going on?
Get out.
Number the
end down at 10,000.
Possible. Easy.
Roger that.
To maintain
one zero thousand and one April
are going to
be the nature of the emergency
and your intentions.
Seattle, Alaska
Public Justice Department.
We think they're getting down to 10,000.
You can hear the pilots
with their muffled voices.
Likely they had oxygen
masks on to the left side
of the airplane's fuselage
is where this failure occurred.
There is a door
that can be installed
at the Boeing factory.
It depends on the seating
configuration ordered by the airline.
This airplane in particular
did not have it.
Instead,
it has a plug that you can see
on the outside of the airplane there.
You wouldn't know about it
from the inside.
This plane in particular
rolled off the factory floor
only ten weeks ago
from Renton, Washington,
first flight, October 15th,
150 flights for Alaska Airlines
since then.
Boeing now
under the microscope
once again
after a litany of issues
with the 737 max.
Two major crashes abroad,
346 people killed.
Grounded in the U.S. for 18 months.
And the Boeing has been dogged
by quality control issues since.
The good news
here, 171 passengers on board,
six crew, all okay.
And the crew did an exceptional job.
Oh, they really did.
I mean, that is great news.
Great news there.
But this is really rattling,
you know, a lot of people.
So any indications
now that other airlines
might ground their 737 nine max jets?
This is the latest data from Cirium,
which looks at the global airline fleet.
And they say there are about 215
737 max nines in use around the world.
One of the biggest operators,
United Airlines, they have 79 of them.
We've reached out to comment
to see what they will do,
although we do know now
that Alaska Airlines,
all 65 of its planes,
are temporarily grounded,
pending inspections
of this specific spot.
Alaska Airlines CEO says
that will take only a few days time,
although we will see
what transpires here.
The National Transportation Safety Board
digging into this
along with the federal Aviation
Administration.
For an adding to the alarm.
I mean, this is a young aircraft
just ten weeks old.
All right.
Pete Montaigne,
thank you so much
for checking back with you
as you learn more.
So let's talk
more about the analysis of
this is going to retired 777 Captain
Les Abend.
Good to see you.
So what's your reaction,
your initial reaction to hear that
a piece of a Boeing 737
nine max plane would simply,
you know,
fall off, get sucked away
and frighten a whole lot of people?
Well, I'm flabbergasted, Fredricka.
I just it's hard for me
to imagine,
regardless of the fact
that Alaska uses
that or
does or does not utilize that particular
section as a emergency exit,
that was a service to her.
Pete did a great job of
pretty much describing,
you know what that was all about.
But at the end of the day,
it's a plug type door is what we call it.
It's like like a bank vault.
That that door,
if it was used as an emergency
exit,
should have sealed
tight against that airplane.
How it came out
is just unfathomable to me.
But in any case,
the crew did a tremendous job, as we as
you just talked about.
But the first thing you've got to do
is take care of yourself
up in the cockpit.
And that's
and the very first thing
that we do is we put on our oxygen mask.
Now, they were only at 16,000 feet,
so they had enough oxygen.
It would have got a little dicey
had they been up there longer,
but or been at the much higher altitude.
That's the other part of it.
It's good that it came off
when it did the
and then once you start
with the oxygen mask,
you start a checklist, like Pete said,
and you come down very quickly.
However,
one of the caveats of coming down
is, is to say, well,
should we come down
fast or do we have a possible
structural integrity issue?
And guess what?
They probably thought they did.
Got a call
from flight attendants and say,
hey, I think
the side of the fuselage
has a big hole in it.
So they probably took a little more time
than they would have.
When I looked at the flight aware data,
they could have come down a lot faster.
But I think they were
they were using their best judgment.
And I and I applaud them for that.
So in any case,
all the oxygen masks
will automatically come down.
But it certainly was a very
harrowing situation
for the passengers back there.
But the crew did tremendous.
And we celebrate them, thank goodness.
So
when it comes down to the analysis of the
what happened, you mentioned a seal.
Okay?
This is a space
where there's an option
for it to be a door or the windows.
In this case,
you said it was a plug door.
So what kind of seal
is traditionally around it?
Might that be the area
that's compromised?
Because this isn't a new configuration.
This is something
that is, you know, customary
and on a lot of planes.
But something obviously went wrong.
This is a ten week old aircraft.
What's the first order of business
in trying to figure out
how and why this was compromised?
Well, if this was a plug type door,
that could have been used as an option,
as a service door, which would
become an emergency exit,
like I
said, it's a bank vault
type door situation.
So having those
there's pins
that surround that whole thing.
The seal is just to
just reinforce all of that.
And so having that door come open
with a pressurized airplane,
it just it's amazing to me.
I don't know how
that could happen
unless it wasn't constructed properly.
And if this door was functional
in any particular way,
the cockpit would have seen a message
that said, Hey, this door is open.
And so it's wise.
In your view then, that,
you know, immediately
these kinds of aircrafts,
you know, part of any fleet
would be suspended, you know, grounded
while they carry out the investigation.
The NTSB is sending a go team
to Portland to investigate.
From that standpoint.
It's an extraordinary
circumstance
and I understand why they're doing it.
You know,
let's not start talking
about the history of the max.
No, this certainly isn't related
to the
the M care system that we knew back
in 2019. But,
you know, like like Pete said,
there are some quality control
aspects to this airplane.
And we're hoping that
that Boeing gets it right
or this is an anomaly.
You know, this is a one off
situation
that could have been under human control
that we're not aware of at this point.
Is it an anomaly
to have this kind of door
option configuration?
Is it specific to the 737
nine max planes,
or do we need to be concerned about this
same kind of
option configuration on other aircrafts?
We shouldn't be concerned about this.
All airlines order their planes
in different types of configurations
when it comes to seating,
when it comes to a cockpit arrangement.
So, you know,
this is not unusual from that standpoint.
I guess
Alaska decided,
you know,
because they have enough emergency exits
for an evacuation situation
that they didn't necessarily
have to utilize this door.
So they utilized it for seating.
All right.
Let's say, Ben, thank you so much.
Of course,
we are all glad that all passengers,
all crew are okay.
Pretty shaken up, probably, but okay.